I know a little about the history of Iran
because you made a course for LingQ
which has 26 lessons about the history of Iran
I have studied this course
but we should study the same topic in different contexts several times
so that gradually we learn it and get better and better
So, from Greece to Central Asia
and India, this region is very important culturally and historically
and a thousand years ago
Central Asia
used to be a cultural center
it was a center for science
while Europe had a lower level of culture and science
So, it's very interesting, Samarghand, Bukhara...
I have decided to start this challenge
this 90-days challenge
to collect at least 400 coins every day
it's not difficult,
very quickly I can gain more than a thousand coins
but I have two goals,
first, to collect more than 400 coins
this is the default level
if I choose insane level, the highest number of coins is 400
but usually I collect more than 1000 coins every day
at the same time, I want to learn 50 new words every day
in the past 2,3 days I managed to maintain this record
In language learning, the progress is very slow
I don't feel the progress
but every day I keep listening and every day I find words I don't know or I know
but if I see more and more blue and white words on my reader
it means I have made a progress
and also on my stats, if the number of known words reaches 15000 it means progress has happened
every morning I do my listening
and I do my reading, sentence by sentence on LingQ
and I keep lingqing
my study time depends on my daily activities
if we play golf with my wife
I don't find much time to study
So, in such days I study in the evening
I may also study again what I have listened to earlier in the morning
during your Persian learning, if for one day you switch to studying another language
does this affect your Persian?
it's interesting
I like to read a book in German before going to sleep
it doesn't affect
because my level is high in German, there is no problem
when I listen to Persian
or read
there is no problem
but when I try to speak Persian
there is an influence from different other languages
like Japanese... Russian
I can't control my brain
it all goes in the wrong direction
but there is no problem when it comes to comprehension
and sometimes there is the influence of Arabic language
I wonder whether a word is Arabic...or it is Persian...
but not a big issue
if I continue practicing my Persian the way I do now
sometimes other languages affect the process, but not big a problem.